hey everybody it's Charlie if you
haven't seen it Marvel released the
final part of their infinity war pre
loot story that's canon to the movies so
like whenever big movies come up there
is released some comic book or a story
to explain what's been going on and fill
all the gaps in the timeline since the
end of black panther in thor ragnarok so
what this story does is it sort of tells
you where some of those moments like
during thor ragnarok where that thor
scene takes place what Doctor Strange
has been doing since the end of his
movie with the other Avengers like
Captain America have been doing since
the end of civil war so let's break it
down because it gets really heavy into
what the Avengers know about the
Infinity stones in Doctor Strange knows
a little bit more than the other
Avengers like Tony Stark has an idea for
what's coming because the mine stone and
Scarlet Witch showed him a vision of the
future remember that line from a Loki
during Ragnarok when Thor was making fun
of his clothes he was talking about
Scarlet Witch was I supposed to know
can't see into the future a little wish
so let's just break this down there's
that Infinity Gauntlet giveaway that's
going on now all you have to do to enter
just be a subscriber and leave a comment
on the video I'll start with part 2
because that deals with more of the
Doctor Strange Infinity stones stuff
I've already talked a little bit about
the other Avengers but I'll circle back
around for them and tell you what it
confirms because one of the first big
things that it does is it canonized as
what happened to Red Skull at the end of
that first Captain America film we've
all had our own explainers but this just
makes it official so he's alive and he's
out there but start with a Doctor
Strange stuff because we sort of see
this from his perspective so think about
all this Doctor Strange long talk about
Infinity stones what they can do what
their powers are where they're located
while Thor is looking for Odin Wong
comes in to interrupt Doctor Strange in
a sort of funny way like this still a
bit of a comedic energy between the two
of them and says haven't you felt this
foreboding as of late they remember what
Mordo said at the end of the Doctor
Strange movie about the bill coming due
the price that they would pay for
messing with the natural order of things
talking specifically about unleashing
the time stone to rollback time and then
defeat Dormammu who still think there
will be no consequences strange
no price to pay we broke our rules just
like the bill comes do you always I
reckon
dr. strange acknowledges what Mordo said
but he believes that the benefits
outweigh any potential cost that they
would pay for using the infinity stone
then Wong asks him what he knows of the
other Infinity stones
he knows that five others exist so like
he knows that the soul stone exists Wong
knows more than he does and he sort of
gives him a quick history about how
Okimoto had the time stone used it for
good others sought it for power that's
when he sort of gets into the spiel
about the history of the other Infinity
stones that we've seen in the MCU
starting with the Red Skull and the
space stone then they give you sort of
tour of the MCU phase 1 phase 2 and
phase 3 so far and let you know exactly
what the earth-based Avengers know of
the current whereabouts of the Infinity
stones all the Avengers on earth
including Tony Stark who hasn't met
Doctor Strange yet I know everybody's
waiting for moustache Bros Sherlock bros
and moustache grows from the MCU they're
just gonna be too many awesome moments
there Doctor Strange in the masters of
the mystic arts like Wong know way more
about the Infinity stones than Iron Man
so you sort of used Doctor Strange as
the template so they do not know about
the events of the guardians of the
galaxy movie they still think the Power
Stone is on morass they don't know that
Peter quill stole it then gave it to
Nova prime at the end of that guardians
of the galaxy movie r.i.p Nova prime
poor went out for her because that's
where Thanos is gonna go first but the
other important thing is that they also
don't know that Thanos exists they don't
know that he's searching for the gems
they just sense this grand cosmic unease
like if you saw a storm rolling in on
the horizon they know about the reality
stone and what happened on earth during
Thor the dark world but they don't know
that the Asgardians gave the reality
stone to the collector and if you didn't
see it I already posted that scene of
Thanos coming to take the reality stone
from the collector so I'll add a link
for that at the end of this then they
sort of clarify what Baron von Strucker
did with the mine stone to the twins he
was trying to experiment on the effects
of the Infinity stones on human tissue
and that's what
gave them powers it was sort of the
reaction to that but what they don't
explain is that Scarlet Witch has a
special connection to the Infinity
stones and she can tap into their power
in a way that other people can't because
that's where her powers flow from in a
sort of recontextualizes this scene
during civil war where she's fighting
vision and she tries to leave what she's
doing here isn't just using her power to
telekinetically throw him through a
couple floors into the basement just to
keep him busy for a while
she's also emceeing him a little bit to
disable him using the mine stone that's
why when she starts activating her
powers the mine stone itself in his
forehead lights up
they haven't explained any of that we
just know that on a really low level
she's able to control them but I suspect
that she'll be key in getting the
gauntlet off of tanis's hand once he
assembles all the Infinity stones then
right before they start talking about
the soul stone this scene happens well
that was going on you set the picture
Wong in a different part of the sanctum
just waiting for dr. strange to come
back so they could continue their
conversation so then Wong asks and what
he knows of the soul stone and dr.
strange doesn't know a lot about it or
its whereabouts but Wong calls it the
most dangerous of all threats because I
think what they're trying to lead into
is the idea of what it actually can do
you know on a really low level ability
it can just change people's alignment so
imagine you have all the Avengers that
are trying to fight Thanos all of his
children like Gamora nebula the Black
Order so imagine the Avengers defeat the
Black Order and it's just a nose-first
the Avengers if he has the soul gem he
can change their alignment
so imagine Gamora hates Thanos wants to
take him down he can turn her evil again
without having to MC her because MC
implies that she really doesn't like him
and she's being forcefully made to do
things the soul gem just like
fundamentally changes your personality
when you have the Infinity Gauntlet and
the effects of the soul gem are
amplified by the power stone which is
basically what it does it as the powers
of all the other stones you can do that
for everybody at the same
you have to imagine that relatively
quickly after this Hulk comes crashing
through the sanctum because remember
this conversation is happening while the
events of thor ragnarok are happening
before thor went upon Sekar remember
there's a time dilation field so that
even though loki was there for a couple
of weeks in reality not that much time
had passed for the rest of the universe
so with the end of thor ragnarok when
Thanos shows up to steal the space stone
maybe like less than a couple of weeks
have passed since the end of this
conversation that dr. strange has with
Wang so very quickly after this you see
Hulk crash through the sanctum iron man
shows up in Thanos in the Black Order
are on earth trying to get the other
stones but while this has been going on
since civil war Iron Man has just been
brooding over his vision of everybody
dying he thinks that it's the future
that's going to come to pass so he
doesn't know who fan o says but he knows
that something terrible is coming and
he's trying to prepare for that so he's
just tinkering with his brand-new
bleeding-edge armor which thanks to a
lot of the toys we've actually gotten a
much better look at he's got Spider Man
suit in the background here if you
haven't seen Tom Holland posting
pictures there most definitely some arms
that come out of a backpack that
attached to his back when he's wearing
that suit while this has been going on
since the end of civil war Captain
America Black Widow and Falcon all
fugitives from justice have been doing
the exact same thing that you saw at the
beginning of Captain America Civil War
trying to keep dangerous weapons out of
the hands of terrorists all this is
happening while Black Panther is
happening so Winter Soldier is still
that broken white boy that sure he is
trying to fix otherwise he would
probably be helping them out he makes a
couple references to Iron Man like
should we call a Tony and to help us
with this mission no I don't want to
bother him he's probably busy with other
things
Tony is also thinking about calling
Captain America and brooding on that
Iron Man is still understandably salty
about what happened to his parents so
obviously it's gonna be a tense reunion
so I don't want to say water under the
bridge but the threat of phantos just
completely wipes any of that drama aside
so he immediately calls cap when banner
crashes through the sanctum and he winds
up here but hopefully that explains the
prelude story I know it's a little bit
longer you can actually buy it on
comiXology right now if you want to read
it but they do this for every really big
movie so like hey it's been a while
these are what the characters have been
doing a lot of you requested a video on
Thanos as black
I'll do video for them soon we learned a
lot more about what's going on with The
Witcher TV show
we also learned more about Westworld
season 2 so there's a whole bunch of
stuff to post I'll just do updates in
that top pin comment on the video so
just check my comments on the video and
I'll name a giveaway winner when I post
new marble if you didn't see it for some
magical reason Marvel moved the release
date of infinity war up by a week so
everybody gets to watch it one week
earlier than normal it's April 27th all
over the world freaked out about that in
the comments while I make my next video
so click here for that Danno scene where
he comes from the reality stone and
click here for brand new clash thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]